yeah the spinal cord will combine
different signals and then trust me to
have a brain especially the sensory
cortex you will feel each most of the
each receptors rt-pcr so we focus on the
gpcr especially the offensive he shares
expressed in the toaster or the ganglion
neurons so this opens VCRs maybe the
candidates that the mediator is each
actually our you know that in the lab to
demonstrate a principle we have found as
a molecular mechanism of color starting
age for example we have disease screen
the antagonist and we believe that many
promise through course also want to
choose this each because it has a big
market so it can also to this compound
these companies can also target this
each receptor to trade usage and make
fun of the antagonist know someone's
opinion me contradict yours what is my
friend Alan it's all about your
perspective who are we in what is the
nature of this reality
[Music]
Nihao everybody and junk check koala
happy mid-autumn festival we are in the
beautiful Beijing China
welcome to simulation I'm your host Don
Saucon we are at the School of Life
Sciences here we are now going to be
talking about the sensory GPCR of itch
we have ten junjou joining us on the
show
hello hi June hi Ellen thank you so much
for coming on our show
yeah we appreciate it very excited for
this conversation for those who don't
know Jun's background he's a graduate
researcher in the Lee lab at Peking
University School of Life Sciences focus
on the sensory GPCR of itch and you can
find all the links in the bio below June
let's start things off by asking you one
of our favorite questions what are your
thoughts on the general direction of our
world oh it's an interesting question
yeah yes general and you know that there
are more and more technologies for our
life especially it's convenient for our
life take example you know that the
alipay you have used it out of each LP
so I think for the future these advanced
technologies will help ours to bat early
life in this planet and I think actually
I'm offering
maybe the AI will replace me yeah for
the future yeah it's probably and but I
think it's a mainly difference between
the human is a ice-t-- idea I think the
idea is important and I don't think
today I will replace the smartest people
in the world because yeah you know that
as I mentioned it can help us to this
repeated works yeah you need a kind of
task yeah yeah but the creative ones is
much harder for it so it's also depends
on human yeah yeah yeah and then yeah
yeah it's totally the general direction
of now technology augmenting our lives
in so many ways our health our educate
our day-to-day processes AI narrow AI
doing repetitive tasks way better than
humans is very quickly happening but AI
doing creative tasks is slow slower and
happening right now and the building
general intelligence is is also very
difficult how do you get a computer
system to recognize space and time is
very hard and but who knows in terms of
replacement of us as humans are at least
augmenting us for sure replacing us
we've had that conversation many times
on our show it's it's a it's for sure
fun one and we'll see exactly what ends
up happening with that let's talk about
your your journey so where were you born
how did you pick up your interest in
science growing up oh he's a cool
question actually I'm interested in
biology I mean the Nitro sized we are mo
there was a child where we were born
yeah what they are yes okay I'm mark
born in Shandong Province east for China
and when I was a kid I'm interesting for
example why the most creative users each
so you know that is yeah it's a terrible
mm-hmm especially when we live - yeah
near water yeah it's very terrible so
how to say I'm interested in Natural
Sciences we another child and when I am
aiming hours and agree to your students
in the in my university the northwestern
curtain of forest university in Chien
province the west of China and because
in our university there is no
neuroscience lab hmm so I searched the
literature and I found that the most
great we induced each is very complex
and yet you know we have note that hated
me because to buy some compounds
released from our such as immune cells
and then triggered each yeah and you
know for me a to me and the mall has
more and more research is worse down the
deeper you thinking or a deeper you
understanding the more I want to know
why does why I'm interested in science
yes yes so when you were a little kid it
was as simple as just why is a mosquito
bite caused me to itch and then that got
you when you were in biotechnology and
the northwest
anf University yeah you've kept going
into interest in that yeah maybe
and then you ended up we'll talk about
this move to picking University and
doing neuroscience here but I'm so
interested in even the most fundamental
aspects of what you were talking about
with the mosquito and the itch what do
you know about why we each from the
mosquito bite okay you mean your
question is better or why we want to
know the magneto each yeah and why even
the mechanism of itch from the mosquito
happens why do we each it's like the
immune response oh yeah okay yes see I
say actually the each include acute each
and chronic itch the mosquito induced a
securities or a cute one and it means
that each last shorter for six weeks
chronic itch in the last over six weeks
especially on some systemic disease we
let's back to the Q th the Q th actually
is a protective behavior it will help us
to to expel a stimulus such as a
mosquitoes or some plants toxic plants
okay so it's protect you for our
survival
yeah and as for the Magnezone I think is
very complex
it includes the immune system the
neuroscience you have to be here to be
here oh yeah sometimes it seems like
when I get a mosquito bite that if I
itch it lasts longer than if I don't
itch what do you think about that okay I
means that the scratch it's more scratch
it's more each yeah you have more H
equals longer no longer mosquito bite I
say so teacher of the magnesia he's
unknowing and I think it may be caused
to by a feedback loop I mean it's a more
each sorry two more scratch your skin
the more each she's happen mm-hmm it's
also interesting learning from you that
even something as simple as what we
experience within the mosquito bite has
such a complex both the this peripheral
skin layer complex here plus complex
with how it triggers our nervous system
and our behavior of doing this process
of Achor our immune system all the types
of this is very complex even something
simple like a mosquito but yeah I see
actually as you mentioned that it's a
circuit it's a neural circuit okay
the stimuli will yeah will activate the
sensor in our skin for example receptor
to each especially that each receptor
and the signal will transmit to the
spinal cord
yeah the spinal cord will combine
different signals and then trust me to
our brain especially the sensory cortex
you will feel each and yeah the upstream
is the receptor I mean the sensors that
are stimulated or activity to bite
external stimuli and these receptors
mainly expressed in our primary sensory
neurons and this sensory neurons is so
called the dorsal root ganglion
yours not only each the dose root
ganglion neurons will be I mean will
control different assumed metro
sensation including each pen temperature
even the mechanical sense very
interesting yeah
and this primary sensory neuron will
combine these signals and then trans to
to inter neurons in the spinal cord
that's in your brain Wow okay
do it one more time dorsal root ganglia
with neurons okay and that's located in
the basal ganglia yeah okay okay and so
this is very more more limbic structure
the lower brain structure not higher
cortex structure lower brain structure
yeah so more older structure the
immunise in this response so so both
mechanical touch temperature and pain
yeah and each each somatosensory the
combination of all of those yes sorry is
in this dorsal root yeah okay sorry
Soto sorta ganglia the neurons it's a
heterogeneous a heterogeneous and the
prior studies have know that the small
diameter neurons will mediator each and
append the large diameters will control
our such as a mechanical mm-hmm as for
the temperature that depends on the
expression of different temperature
related such as the ion channels and as
I mentioned this small diameter neurons
will control nearly all of the nonsense
options including pen each okay okay and
then how are we learning that the the
dorsal root ganglia how do we know that
that Center is responsible for
somatosensory
[ __ ] example yeah how do how do we know
that that area is responsible for the
somatosensory do we do
neural mapping general imaging of that
Center when you know when you poke or
when you scratch and you see that area
have activation okay if I understand
correctly you mean how do we
characterize this sensory neurone for
example to each neuron indeed control
that each incision okay
actually there are many yeah
technologies can help us to that
for example the single say orange stick
yeah we can pick one single neuron as in
sequenced yeah there MRA will help ours
to identify which genes expressed in
this mural is single neuron if this
neuron expressed a well known each
receptor such as it's a mosquito each
receptor we have note that this neuron
could mediate the most Cretu induced to
each by the way the most griddle induced
each is media divided a histamine
released by the master seal I mean the
mosquitoes the bite of the mosquito such
as may be sad organic se exit or
stimulate our immune cells such as a
master co and Master surgeon released
histamine and as a histamine
it's true origin I mean the each causing
compound it will activate his receptor
the histamine receptor especially the h1
receptor and each flow receptor
expressed in the small diameter TRG
neurons so yeah back to this question
if we sequenced the genes expressed in
the single neuron and we found that this
new I expressed the histamine wine is
for receptor so we have reason to
believe this neuron could immediate as a
histamine use to each yes okay okay just
single co-artistic is powerful and so
we're doing single-cell RNA sequencing
on the basil root ganglia are on the
dorsal root cellar that can't get on the
dorsal root ganglia and that gave us the
understanding that it expresses
specifically for for each actually yeah
yeah actually as I mentioned it can help
it can tell ours whether this neuron for
the indeed expressed each receptor or
not but the director question that
whether this receptor expressed in this
neuron is functional so we need to do
some other experiments to help ours to
demonstrate or characterize whether this
neuron is indeed a functional in the for
example each transmission and the to
achieve this yeah as I mentioned we can
do many different kinds of experiments
one
it's the Kelsey imaging because if the
neuron its activity the intracellular
calcium will be increased either through
the extracellular calcium influx or the
release of the calcium from the
intracellular hurt the ER part and I
mean the calcium is released from air to
the cytoplasmic the intracellular
increase of the calcium will activate
this neuron you know that the
neurotransmitter release is depend on
the calcium increase so the calcium
imaging I mean this experiment will help
us to test whether this neuron is indeed
a functional in this process for example
I can buy the histamine I mean the pure
histamine compound and then treated the
neurons mm-hmm if this neuron is
expressed a functional histamine
receptor to mediate each the application
of the administration of histamine will
activate this neuron so this neuron I
mean the intracellular calcium will be
increased if we use the one calcium
indicator
to help ours to distinguish whether the
intracellular calcium in this neuron is
increased we can distinguish this
interesting intracellular calcium
increase okay means that it's expressing
to its activities active over this mural
okay okay so that's one in single cell
or in a sequencing is it another part of
actually there's a to distinguish per
two different ways one the singles are
artistic it's demonstrated to expression
your other receptors the calcium imaging
all the electrophysiology is
demonstrated at function of the receptor
or this mural okay
what's the expression and the function
yeah yeah the expression and the
function gives you the knowledge that
that's what's going on yeah yeah how
about let's talk about this from the
explanation of
gpcr g-protein coupled receptors yeah
okay
so apparently there's lots of them on
the outside of every cell do we know
about how many on the outside of every
cell lots you know the number so would
you be serious in our body
yeah yeah i me bullets do try every cell
how many no no not every still not every
it's not a Mercer how which cells have
GP sharing which ones don't
it depends okay as I mentioned of if
this receptor could mediate such as each
pen and this is GPCRs may be exclusively
expressed in the primary sensory neurons
the DRT the dorsal root ganglion neurons
mm-hmm
if this receptor for the midis immunes
this immune reaction this gpcrs these
receptors may be expressed in the immune
cells such as the master cell or
microfiche it depends okay but all
neurons and glia cells have GPCR
receptors hmm or a lot do or sorry okay
how many of the brain cells have gpcr
receptors
I think nearly all the neurons nearly
all neurons nearly all neurons of the
expressed VCR but up but not all of the
GBC rose okay okay yeah yeah no our body
there are nearly 800 GP series yes okay
there are some identified TV series I
mean the function is a nolan and the
some others are orphaned gb terms means
they're in tightness ligand unknown so
called offensive you sir for your
question
I think for nearly all that neurons the
brain neurons could express several gb
cell
for example the glutamate receptor
mm-hmm but not all of the TV series okay
okay okay okay and then when we when we
look at the GP shell receptor this is
something that is about forty or fifty
percent of all FDA drugs are targeting
GP shell receptors so this is a big
field yeah people care a lot about being
able to target molecular compounds to
gpcr receptors so how do you know what
GPR receptors are related to itch is
that what we were talking about earlier
with the the the dorsal root ganglia
that that those cells have GPCR
receptors for itch mm-hmm okay okay so
yeah is that what we were talking about
earlier with the so your question is how
do we characterize on receptors or each
receptor yes okay
as I mentioned firstly from the X in the
expression level it'll show that Express
a this receptor is a each receptor it
should express in the primary sensory
neural the daughter of the can get in
Europe after that we need to demonstrate
their function
oh it's functioned yes yeah into each
passing expression function yeah yeah
and specifically the dorsal root ganglia
mm-hm
okay okay and then so then you are
always targeting dorsal root ganglia
GPCR receptors
yeah that's your okay okay because
that's always where itch is yeah gonna
become okay okay
holy static disease okay cholestasis
call us turn tease cholestasis
obstructing the flow of bile from the
liver yeah okay so bile from our liver
is what tells us to itch okay so yes
okay you know that in the physiological
condition the bio will reach to the
intestine from the liver especially in
the duodenum which is a part of small
intestine and as a bio such as a bar s
it will help her to digest the food but
there is a condition of the disease
called so called collister T's means
there is some blockage so the bio cannot
reach to the in testing but accumulating
in the liver and it's through the
systemic circulation this accumulated a
bio for example the bile acids the Billy
Ruby our compounds contained in the bio
will reach to our body tissues through
the systemic circulation such as serum
or skin and it's a major symptom of the
cholestatic patient it's each to severe
each I mean the color chronic itch or
six weeks and but the mechanism is still
unknown but actually two thousand years
ago a Greek physician found that or
hypothesis that maybe some commas
continued Empire cost each from a from
his clinic observation so we have poses
that may be some compounds Candida
Empire it's each causing compound okay
and then compounds in bio are it's
causing okay in Hamas our internal parts
and if the bio builds
up in the liver and doesn't if the flow
is obstructed like in cholestasis then
the itch just goes the chronic edge
happens with the build-up of bile okay
supply acids as I mentioned if we could
accumulate in the liver
suja systemic circulation it we all
reach to other body tissues including
skin and we have posted an elevated the
levels or bio acids may be triggered on
each but the question that what's the
receptor that immediate this each we
don't know okay okay okay
buildup of bio acid in liver causes
chronic itch mm-hmm okay
hmm so the obstructed flow so if bile
was flowing then we wouldn't be itching
okay it's interesting point
as for the actually there are several
therapies for the cholestatic each one
of them is a resin it's a craze is a
resin so called cholestyramine it's a
strong iron resin I mean it's real
absorbs the bio acids to form insoluble
complex then secret it from our body
tissue and the patient's after usage of
this cholestyramine this each is relief
it's decreased I mean the decreased so
we have posited that the decrease the
bio acids cost as a decrease to each
symptom
so maybe the bio acids is the each
causing compounds yes okay okay
whoof okay so now we also figure out
that there's a process with the bile
acid that then also is when it induces
the
so the bio acid compound inducing itch
but then we also are trying to figure
out how with chronic itch to block the
GPCR receptors so that in the dorsal
root ganglia so that I don't chronic
itch yeah so you want to make a
molecular compound to block to gpcr
receptor so that I don't age exactly to
achieve this we need to know the exact
of the receptor that immediately is each
so our lab I interested in this question
and as I mentioned this year's study
have know that most of the each
receptors rt-pcr so we focus on the GPC
are especially the offensive is years
expressed in the dorsal root ganglion
neurons so this offensive is earnest
should appear candidates may be the
candidates that the mediator is each so
we analyzes the sick data I mean the
sequencing data of the human dorsal root
ganglion neuron and we found several
offensive is earns that highly expressed
in this turning neurons I mean in the
human turns in yours so this offensive
ecr's as I mentioned it should I be the
candidate that emitted is each so when
we found that this movie Fontes firstly
we use the bio extracts the bias tracks
to test whether the bio extract could
activate this offensive ecr's if the
this receptor or maybe one of several
geezers could be activated by the bias
tracks it should be a each receptor at
least a candidate receptor and actually
we performed this and we found that the
bio extract could a specific
they activate aware of the offensive is
ears very luckily and we found that it
is MIT prx for that highly expressed in
human TRG neurons so the bio extract is
complex I mean there are many different
compounds including biases bilirubin and
some other compounds so after that we
want to know the exact a compound I mean
the active component contained in the
bio s tracks that activate this MIT px
for this receptor so after the chemical
separation and such as the mass spectrum
you know that the mass tractor or EMR
and we identified it is bio acid it's
the active component to activate this
receptor yeah okay and then you have to
figure out out of 2,000 molecular
compounds of which one is going to do
the blocking of the GPCR receptor see if
did you have to run two thousand of
these experiments to see actually evenly
found that MIT px4 bike among other
experiments we have demonstrated this
receptor is each receptor that immediate
is about as is induced Collister each in
human so after the data we want to know
or we hypothesis that if we could have
found a compound that is specifically
block has this receptor
yeah it should be a drug candidate for
this each symptom yes and actually we
have disease whispering nearly two as
you mentioned nearly two thousand
compounds and we have found some
candidates and we think we can find a
compound that can block this receptor
but it's not enough you know that if we
want to further develop this compound
from bench to clinical we need to
demonstrate them
different properties of this compound
such as the potency affinity toxicology
yeah so if we found this compound we
need to collaborate with such as
chemical groups to perform the chemical
modulation of phantoon the structure of
this candidate to God to get a potent
one especially specific the specificity
is very important because we don't want
to get other side effect and we found if
we found this potent the compound I mean
the antagonists have this receptor
either for the earth that's the
candidate okay for this each okay
so then it could be that the about two
hundred thousand people in the USA per
year and I don't know how many worldwide
probably millions of people in the
worldwide that have polio static disease
can then potentially use of Pharma logic
Formica logical aid in order to prevent
their chronic itch from happening okay
so this is one of the health outcomes of
your scientific research yeah
actually there are no efficient therapy
for this treatment I mean for these
colors thirty each the traditional
method that used the colostomy as I
mentioned but it will cause severe
constipation and because of his taste
the severe test a the patients found ate
and played ball and yeah so we think if
we find a drug especially our candidate
is should be very efficient for this
it's impotent in addition to treating
itch where else could science like this
help us okay
in addition to each there are many
different sensory cemento sensations
such as a pen or temperature or the
mechanical the pain it's also a severe
run so if we find a pen I mean the
specific receptors in the media the pen
we can treat the pen symptom with the
similar strategy like when I have a very
severe surgery and I have several weeks
of severe pain that we could block the
gpcr receptor for pain mm-hmm yeah yeah
the traditional method such as the
muffin Morphin yeah potato had severe
side effects such as the addiction hi or
addiction because there are many of
morphine receptors expressed in our
brain but if we if we cannot achieve the
specificity it will cause a severe study
effect for our each receptor as I
mentioned before it is specifically
expressed in the dorsal root ganglion
neurons if we find our candidate or
antagonist of this receptor supposedly
it will not influence our C as the
central nervous system because it can
specifically target to this receptor but
not other receptors so targeting pain
very specifically rather than in the
whole numbing of the whole yeah okay
okay
it's employed yeah exactly okay and
maybe even yeah temperature maybe even
the mechanical okay okay okay okay
now what about where do you see your
work here at the lab where do you see
your work going with you think then do
you need up do you need to partner with
a
a pharmacological institution to help
you develop the molecular compound for
you to actually be able to go and
deliver that to the GPCR receptors to
block the itch for the chronic itch
patients exactly
actually our word you know that in the
lab to demonstrate a principle I mean we
have found as a molecular mechanism of
color starting each for example we have
disease screen the antagonist and we
believe that many farmers to course also
want to choose this each because it has
a big market so it can also to this come
on these companies can also target this
each receptor to treat the disease
I mean find out the antagonist do you
know what it would look like for a lab
that found the molecular mechanism of
itch of a chronic itch mmm-hmm to work
with a pharmacological company like what
do you do do you say here's our research
paper mm-hmm
will you guys make the molecular
compounds and then continue helping us
fund this project and we collaborate on
it and then we own we split the IP the
intellectual property how does it work
if that happens actually we can
collaborate with some pharmaceuticals
and we can also build up our all in
pharmaceutical yeah yeah to develop a to
come home yeah to the clinical trial yes
yes okay I'm curious like what the yeah
what the split in ownership is or what
the funding is like do they help fund
the lab if you guys have really good
research that they want to use you know
that's an interesting question the
relationship between a pharmaceutical
company in the lab that's doing yeah
research yeah what would be a ideal
neuroscience tool for you let's say 50
or a hundred years down the line where
we're doing everything that we want to
do with the brain
what would that tool look like okay no
question what is the most efficient tool
in your size yeah and fifty or a hundred
years down the line for the future yeah
what would that look like what would
that to look like I think it may be
called optogenetics yeah you know the
channelrhodopsin yeah if we can find
express channelrhodopsin it a actually
design channel in the neuron we can just
use a light to stimulate this neuron to
all activate react with this neural
activity yeah so if we want to treat
some disease caused by the sensory I
mean the neuroscience the nervous system
we can express this optogenetic related
in channels in the brain and the user
light to activate or inactivate the
neurons so I think the optogenetic as if
they're powerful yeah yeah agreed
Duchenne x is a massive one okay okay
how about on a on a global collaboration
level how can we increase people around
the world working together oh it's
interesting honesty it's important for
the collaboration yeah and we need to
share our Stata with each other but I'm
not hiding them and besides that I think
the policy is important mm-hmm I mean
the government the policy is important
to for the collaboration especially from
different countries
honest data more clear scientific
communication and collaboration channels
and then just the overall I guess
governmental but also company-wide
collaboration across the world how about
as we go into this exponential
technology era and the 21st century what
is a skill that young people should know
so that they can be highly effective in
the world okay it's hard to say hmm I
think firstly the tool is important for
the technology I mean the tool is
important too for one field to achieve
the hard problem or the question
so maybe the taught development is
important I like that answer
young people going into the new ages
should be focused on tool development I
like that answer
especially because then the tool can
then have other people from around the
world begin using the tool yeah and then
have more creativity more science yeah
yeah yeah like that what about you know
we find ourselves being born onto this
planet orbiting the star there's you
know eight billion of us here a hundred
billion potentially lived and died
before us to build the world what is the
purpose of the human experience what's
the meaning of life okay you mean the
purpose of the hem B yeah okay it's very
interesting to see why and
mmm I think for the better so I wore the
better life is important for the hem
bees okay yeah
the constant process of bettering the
human experience yeah what do you think
about consciousness what is
consciousness
oh it's very complex it's very complex I
think it depends not only the nervous
system it may be enclosed different the
symptom the nervous system immune system
the behavior and the psychologies to my
knowledge I don't think it's a clear
study to demonstrate what is the
consciousness yeah do you think we have
free will sorry do you think we have
free will prevail oh okay maybe hahaha
but yeah you still don't know the magnet
okay it's hard to say yeah the
consciousness is very complex yeah
what do you think is the role of love in
life sorry what do you think is the role
of love in life oh it can now will
encourage yourself to pursue you what
you want to perceive your lie okay and
for me as I mentioned it can help to
release especially when I was in a
depressed
Kempton upset condition the law can help
us to stand out and move on more yeah
love can give us something every day
when we wake up to look forward to
achieving every day yeah falling in love
with what you do and and given that our
computational capacity has been
increasing so fast and our ability to
make simulations of biological systems
and all these types of things do you
feel like our life is a simulation yeah
I sing is a stimulation mmm so complex
okay it depends on the correlation I
mean it depends on a correlation between
different systems yeah
what do you think's the most beautiful
thing in the world hello yeah I think
allow me the most beautiful scene in the
world
the gachy I've ever seen why why why as
I mentioned it's the source of power
yeah yeah yeah mm-hmm I love this this
has been such a fun conversation thank
you very much for joining us thank you
thank you thank you thank you yeah it's
been such a pleasure learning about the
sensory gpcr of itch we would love to
hear your thoughts in the comments below
everyone let us know what you're
thinking and have more conversations to
your friends families co-workers people
online about sensory GPCR about itch
about fixing chronic itch about the
development of the newest sort of
molecular compounds that can help solve
some of these major diseases or issues
with our bodies more conversations about
neuroscience also support you lonely lab
org the links in the bio below support
the artists the entrepreneurs the
leaders the organizations around the
world that you believe in support us
simulation you can find our links below
and support us there and also go and
build the future everyone manifest your
dreams in the world
jeongshik whele happy mid-autumn
festival and also go and build the
future manifest your dreams into the
world thank you very much everyone for
tuning in and we will see you soon
[Music]